- And now, guys, it's time
for tonight's #HashtagWars.
(audience cheers)
(bell dings)
Jared Logan?
- 99 problems and a handy
spreadsheet to handle them all.
- Yes, points! That
would ruin a rap track.
(bell dings)
Dan?
- Titty (bleep) the police.
(audience laughs)
- Points!
(bell dings)
Jamie?
- Jesus walks in Skechers Shape Up shoes.
- Yes, points.
(bell dings)
Jared?
- My mumps.
- Yes, points!
(bell dings)
Jamie?
- The dong thong.
- Oh, I need one of those. Points.
- It's useful.
- It is.
(bell dings)
Jared?
- Straight outta Comcast, I'm in sales.
- Points!
The wardrobe helps sell that, too.
(bell dings)
Dan?
- I'm sorry, Latoya
Jackson, I am for real.
- Points.
(bell dings)
Jared?
- It's hard out there for an imp.
Do you watch Game of Thrones?
- Points, that would
ruin a rap track, yes.
(bell dings)
Jamie?
- It's getting cold in here,
so put on a cable-knit sweater vest.
(buzzer sounds)
(bell dings)
- [Chris] Yes, Scott Aukerman?
- Fred Kreuger, The
Unburned Molesting Janitor.
- Points, points.
(bell dings)
Or, just Regular Dreams on
Elm Street would be another
name for that. James Domian?
- What Can I Do To Roger Rabbit?
- Points,
points.
(bell dings)
Jerry Minor?
- Captain Colonies.
- Yes, points!
(bell dings)
Scott?
- 33 Years Not a Slave.
- Okay, yeah, of course.
- It's optimistic.
The glass is half full.
- Sometimes you gotta
see the other side.
Yeah, points.
(bell dings)
James?
- The Empire Sits Back.
- Points, well done.
(bell dings)
Jerry Minor?
- She Doesn't Have to
Have It Now, Does She?
- Oh, She's Gotta Have It, Spike Lee.
That's points, well done.
(bell dings)
Nate?
- Cheese and Chong.
- Yes, points, points.
(bell dings)
Natasha?
- Sarah Silver-Manischewitz.
- Points, points.
(bell dings)
And culture-appropriate.
Yes, Nate?
- Neil Hamburger.
- Yes, points, already done.
(bell dings)
Marc Maron?
- Bill Burrito.
- Yes, nice, points.
(bell dings)
Nate?
- Paul F. Changs.
- Yes, Paul F. Changs, good. Points.
(bell dings)
Marc Maron.
- Sloppy Joe Rogan.
- Yes, of course! Points.
(bell dings)
Nate?
- Snacks Galifinakis.
(Chris laughs)
- Points.
(bell dings)
Natasha?
- Larry the Cable Guy
Fieri Tequila Poppers.
- Yes, points.
I like it, that's good.
(bell dings)
Yes, Marc?
- Ellen De-generous portion.
- Yes, of course, of course. Points.
(bell dings)
Natasha?
- Marc Marinade.
- [Chris] Yes, Marc Marinade.
(bell dings)
We're stewing in it now. Marc?
- Natasha Leggero my Eggo.
- Yes!
(bell dings)
Lauren?
- You don't know how it feels
to be the only one who
cleans up around here.
- Yes, points! Ah, the guilt.
(bell dings)
Yes, Matt Besser?
- Carry on my wayward
son, but be home by nine.
- Yes, points, points.
(bell dings)
Matt Besser again?
- No rough-housing on
the stairway to heaven.
- Points, points.
(bell dings)
Rich Fulcher?
- Soccer mom-me, Amadeus.
- Points.
(bell dings)
Lauren?
- Who let the dogs out?
Somebody please tell me.
- Points.
(bell dings)
Rich?
- Everybody has visitation on the weekend.
(Chris laughs)
- Yes, divorce mom, yes.
Points.
(bell dings)
Matt?
- Enter the sandman.
Not in my house, take off your shoes.
- Points, points.
(bell dings)
Rich, what?
- R-E-S-P-E-C-T your mother.
(bell dings)
- Rich?
- Blurred c-section lines.
What?